all right so this is the new yellow
iPhone 14 plus so Apple's been doing
these mid-cycle new colors just to keep
the iPhone fresh and talked about there
haven't been that many yellow phones
over the years this one is a
surprisingly polarizing yellow like some
people in the studio love it some people
hate it only one thing feels super
useful to do here compared to other
yellow things so basically this one is a
really safe light pale yellow it's
lighter than almost anything I've
compared it to it's lighter than the
iPhone 10r from a few years ago it's
lighter than a New York City metro card
which kind of feels orange next to this
it makes a banana feel like a much
darker yellow in comparison oh you know
Snapchat yellow they made that pixie
drone it's even lighter than that the
one part of this phone that looks dark
is the sides this is a slightly closer
to a gold color on the side rails
basically the closest two things I found
to match this phone are this Big Bird
plush which came straight from Sesame
Street so it must be accurate and Mac
seems to vastly prefer it over the
iPhone's yellow and that old yellow
subscribe button from the YouTube's past
but you should totally hit that new
subscribe button